[Música]
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 en esta
oportunidad vamos a abordar una de las
consecuencias más duras de la violencia
machista estamos hablando de los niños y
niñas que han quedado huérfanos o en
situaciones de extrema vulnerabilidad
por casos de feminicidios en los que
perdieron a sus madres y en bolivia como
en muchísimos otros países no existen
cifras oficiales pero así el
observatorio para la xxiv y lidad de los
derechos de las mujeres se lanzó a la
tarea de obtener algunas cifras
saludamos por eso a eulogia tapia ella
es activista en contra de la violencia
contra las mujeres a favor de los
derechos de las mujeres e integrante del
observatorio al que hacíamos referencia
neurología tapia muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en la entrevista de france
yo soy más bien le agradecí da un gusto
conocerlos y gracias pues por esta
oportunidad también de poder comunicar
esta realidad tan difícil de ven
bolivianos de niños y niñas que han que
son víctimas de un tema que queremos
visibilizar aquí en france 24 y como
decía eulogia previamente el
observatorio del cual usted hace parte
elaboró un registro no a partir de
reportes de prensa y dan cuenta de 451
niños y adolescentes y también 73
jóvenes verdad que eran dependientes de
sus madres y que quedaron en la orfandad
entre 2016 y el primer trimestre de 2021
eulogia cuéntenos usted que está muy
vinculada a este tema que puede suceder
así en bolivia con estos niños niñas y
jóvenes y en qué situación pueden quedar
imagino que habrá diferencia no
dependiendo de si tienen otros
familiares o no
si nosotros hacemos un registro haciendo
seguimiento a la prensa eso lo que nos
hace ver es de que es posible que
nuestro registro exista sus registros
sea exista muchas más niños y niñas es
seguro que de ver porque en años pasados
no se registraba no se denunciaba la
presencia de la existencia de víctimas
no entonces no tenemos un registro
oficial aquí en bolivia no contamos con
un registro oficial eso hace más difícil
el trabajo de seguimiento si hay algunas
iniciativas que algunas instituciones
han han hecho no con las defensorías del
pueblo o algunas instituciones locales
han hecho investigaciones eso es lo que
tenemos nosotros tenemos estos datos que
indicaba hace un momentito sí pero el
problema aquí que tenemos es que cada
día sube o sea si bien en el momento al
finalizar el mes de marzo habíamos
hablado de 43 niños huérfanos en es en
lo que va del año al momento tenemos
entonces se pueden dar cuenta cómo va la
población aumentando permanentemente y
no para en estos días hemos tenido cinco
mujeres muertas no tres porte municipio
y se habla de dos que han sido suicidios
pero estos suicidios también están
ligadas con el problema de la violencia
normal que tiene que ser también
feminicidios suicidios y que la ley
todavía no los reconoce de esa forma
aquí en bolivia por lo menos no entonces
es una población que quiera
en el desamparo completo son piqué ellas
son las principales víctimas del
feminicidio y la situación de los niños
huérfanos es un problema realmente
grande que la población y el estado no
le está dando solución no hay políticas
que puedan apoyar a esta población y
personal en terranova pero cuál es la
situación concreta con tantos niños
niñas y también jóvenes adolescentes a
dónde van a parar en qué situación
quedan ellos
en el abandono de ser los que tienen yo
diría los que tienen suerte de tener
abuelos y abuelos maternos familiares
que dan con ellos pero también podemos
decir que no todo es permanente no ellos
crecen y empiezan a buscar trabajo se
dispersan en una primera instancia
siempre es el de los niños intentan de
protegerse entre ellos no separarse pero
lamentablemente la vida es dura entonces
tienen que separarse ellos ya los más
pequeños se quedarán otros se van a
trabajar y otros van en orfanatorios no
están no existe un centro digamos que
atiende a esta población porque los
huérfanos por feminicidio es un lugar
con dos especiales no son como el resto
como los otros chicos que que son
huérfanos porque han perdido a su madre
por accidente o por enfermedad éste es
además conlleva un trauma no y este
trauma hace que los chicos
no superen porque ni siquiera tiene un
tratamiento psicológico que es que se
podría que debería ser porque la ley
indica eso no que además tiene que ver
un seguimiento de la defensoría de la
niñez pero no no no pude no se andó
están abandonados suerte muy pocos deben
tener una por lo menos unas dos sesiones
de psicología y porque la familia
después de la muerte de la de la de la
mujer entrar se mete en un engorroso
juicio no entonces que nos absorbe
porque ahí tienen que gastar tienen que
hacer erogaciones no para consultar un
abogado para para las investigaciones y
toda situación y los niños quedan en el
olvido también se nos han atendido
eulogio usted recién hacía un poco de
referencia pero yo quisiera preguntarle
concretamente no cuáles son las secuelas
por llamarlo de alguna manera no que
sufren los niños que perdieron a sus
madres en hechos de violencia machista
de feminicidios
este es un problema que se quedaría
digamos de un estudio más y de un
seguimiento más profundo qué es lo que
pasa muchos de los niños al no haber
superado eso callen también se callen en
un problema de violencia no en sus vidas
algunos
se vuelven demasiado pasivos se llevan
ese dolor adentro y el consep la2
entonces de violencia pero muchos de
ellos no pueden pueden ser víctimas del
consumo de alcohol de muchas situaciones
entonces está esta investigación este
seguimiento que tendría que haber de las
víctimas en este momento no existe
podríamos estar especulando el problema
que tenemos es eso no la falta de
registro y peor seguimiento entonces
hemos visto en algunos casos no tienen
arrastran problemas por supuestos
psicológicos que son frutos de ésta
desde su dolor
y bueno esta es una ausencia digamos que
tiene que tomar en cuenta el estado
porque en estos días ante tanta
violencia se ha hablado de una ley corta
aquí en bolivia y no conocemos el
contenido y lo que tendría que
contemplar es justamente esto hay una
hay una experta diríamos una iniciativa
de la defensoría del pueblo de una ley
para los para las víctimas es decir que
contempla justamente este tema no por un
lado una
protección no es cierto un seguimiento
un acompañamiento de parte de las
autoridades por otro lado un bono
digamos mensual hasta la mayoría de edad
el tema del estudio la salud entonces o
la familia que se está haciendo cargo de
estos niños tenga digamos una
inamovilidad funcionaria para qué
porque hay dentro de esta problemática
un hecho muy duro no porque hay
realidades durísima no también otros
niños y adolescentes que deben digamos
asumir responsabilidades que serían de
adultos no para cuidar a sus hermanos oa
familiares cercanos que perdieron a sus
madres verdad
así es
justamente algunos días oscuros
y adolescentes tienen que asumir el
papel de padre y madre para criar a sus
hermanitos como le decía en ellos
después de la pérdida de la madre porque
es pérdida de madrid' padre no el padre
tiene que ir a la cárcel otras veces
ahí también suicidios después del
feminicidio entonces queda antes en el
completo desamparo y algunos tienen que
asumir ese papel de padre y madre
para cuidar a sus hermanitos hay
experiencias de los que conocemos por
ejemplo que han estado protegiendo a sus
hermanitos intentando internarlos el en
tanto pero no ósea protegiéndose entre
ellos están estos monos los pequeños ya
les llaman papá mamá a sus hermanos hay
experiencias de esas a las que conocemos
también pero no todos los tienen esa
suerte tampoco de tener un hermano o una
hermana que realmente se haga cargo
hasta que salgan y hasta que sean
adultos no muchos van a los centros de
acogida de huérfanos donde no se les da
una atención especializada en los hechos
nos dicen está mejor igual a todos no
hay uno
no no hay un trato especial para las
víctimas de feminicidio ahora haces más
verde que cerraron y tienen que sufrir
todo ese su dolor sólo de absolutamente
cruenta eulogio ahora detrás de todas
estas cifras que recopilaron desde el
observatorio hay como decíamos historias
y tantas historias como personas y cada
historia es particular por supuesto
desde su enorme experiencia eulogia como
ha visto usted que pueden interpretar no
sobre todos los más pequeños estos
hechos de violencia que han visto y que
han vivido en su propia casa
solamente así como como ejemplo
nos contaban los abuelos decían ella es
alegre pero
saben que lleva una carga en un duelo no
resuelto le decía una niña de tres años
no tengo mamá no tengo papá estoy sola
ustedes son mis abuelos no son mis papás
eso les dice una niña de tres años otro
caso que conozco por ejemplo es que
una niña igual de cuatro años les dice
la mamá era una
un artista que habla que le mataron a
mariachi entonces la hija de la mariachi
le dice el frente se encuentra mirando
el espejo de la foto quiero decir la
foto de la madre le decía por qué no
vienes a casa una vez que estoy llorando
le decía la madre a la abuela le dice
abuela contrata un helicóptero vamos
donde mi mamá le habían dicho que la más
debido al cielo
hay historias así trágicas no quiere por
eso decía son traumas que no han sido
superados y tienen que vivir con todo su
dolor y cada persona cada quien tiene
una personalidad también que va formando
bancos tengo que interrumpió la hemos
llegado al final de esta entrevista de
france 24 hablamos abordamos un tema que
merece ser visibilizados y por eso es
que quiero agradecerle muchísimo su
presencia en la entrevista
bueno muchas gracias nos viendo se pintó
otra vez que ustedes me dan la
oportunidad de mostrar esta realidad que
requiere ser tratado absolutamente
entonces estamos en eso luchando para
que nuestras autoridades nos escuchen
gracias a usted ya nuestra audiencia
como siempre le invitamos a continuar
informando se en france 24 y en france
24 punto com
[Música]